hi this is kevin van ORD standing in for
Daniel Starkey to bring you an early
access review of goddess designer Peter
Molyneux is probably best known for his
tendency to oversell his work without
the slightest hint of irony he calls
goddess zen-like and most of the time
that's actually a pretty fair assessment
goddess begins at a more or less
conventional manner you clear out some
rocks and trees to make way for your
followers to build houses and settle
down this is the most basic level of
interaction you have with the game world
every flat piece of land you can clear
or carve automatically generates a plot
on which people can build houses from
here you build up two of the game's
vital resources number of followers and
belief reaching certain numbers of
followers unlocks new powers and
abilities called cards while belief is
continuously generated at homes
belief is the fuel for your God powers
causing drastic changes of any sort uses
exponentially more belief than working
with the lands once these elements have
been introduced
goddess gradually breaks away from the
norm belief for example doesn't
automatically go from your followers
houses to your pool instead you must
collect it from each individual house as
you gradually sculpt the world you also
uncover little stickers that activate
your earned cards as well as a
smattering of strange artifacts temples
and shrines all seemingly left by a
long-dead civilization shrines once
restored unlock more of the game's main
map as well as more stickers and land
for your people to work in the process
eventually your search for stickers in
the main portion of the map will have
you coming up empty that's where
goddesses biggest Edition comes into
play voyages of discovery within the
first few areas you find a special
temple from which you can launch
expeditions to far-off lands each new
island has a terraforming puzzle where
and you must guide your followers from
their landing to their goal in a set
amount of time
this diversion helps fill in what
goddess otherwise has too little of
something interesting to do waiting for
belief to regenerate takes time and
without belief you really can't do much
expeditions help close that gap and keep
you busy instead of simply waiting
around for things to happen
unfortunately they're also out of place
nothing else in goddess is limited by
time or is in any way dangerous to
anything or anyone and so the
possibility of failure in a voyage of
discovery isn't a comfortable fit then
again goddess isn't finished yet and
clearly has a long road ahead of it
still there's truly a pleasurable Evan
flow to collecting belief from your
followers and then using that to sculpt
the lands beneath you